l'union européenne en pleine crise
conjugale
depuis le début de la pandémie de kovy
de 19 les états du vieux continent
peinent à trouver une parade commune et
ce alors que l'europe est pour l'instant
le plus gros foyer d'infection dans le
monde
dernier épisode en date de cette
désunion le conseil européen qui s'est
tenu ce jeudi à couteaux tirés
les vingt-sept ont échoué à s'entendre
sur l'adoption de mesures plus fortes
censé faire face à la récession
économique les corona bands ont
notamment marqué une nette division
entre les membres de lieux destinés à
mutualiser la dette des états européens
face à la crise
ce mécanisme était demandé par une
dizaine de pays dont l'italie l'espagne
ou encore la france même la présidente
de la bce christine lagarde y était
favorable mais refus net de berlin de
l'est ou encore de vienne
nous avons dit du côté allemand mais
aussi de la part d'autres participants
que ce n'était pas la conception de tous
les états membres
nous avons je crois avec le mécanisme
européen de stabilité un instrument de
crise qui ouvre de nombreuses
possibilités et qui ne remet pas en
question les principes de base d'une
action commune et de responsabilité de
chacun c'est là l'ultime résurgence
d'une antique oppositions entre pays du
nord de l'union et ceux du sud
les premiers davantage partisan de la
rigueur budgétaire que les seconds les
divergences qui ont provoqué la colère
du premier ministre italien giuseppe
konté qui a menacé de ne pas signer la
déclaration commune dont le conseil a
accouché le chef du gouvernement italien
a d'ailleurs fait part de son inquiétude
dans la presse nationale ce dimanche
nous devons éviter de faire en europe
des choix tragique
si l'europe ne se montre pas à la
hauteur de ce défi sans précédent
l'édifice européen tout entier risque de
perdre aux yeux de nos propres citoyens
sa raison d'être
l'italie n'est d'ailleurs pas la seule
nation à s'offusquer des positions des
pays du nord
le premier ministre portugais a vivement
critiqué jeudi soir son homologue
néerlandais qui aurait proposé que la
commission européenne enquête sur les
faiblesses budgétaires des pays du sud
face à l'épidémie
ce type de discours est répugnant dans
le contexte actuel de l'union européenne
c'est le terme exact répugnant ce genre
de réponse avec son inconscience absolue
et ce genre de mesquineries récurrentes
ap totalement l'esprit de lieux et
constitue une menace pour son avenir
si l'union européenne veut survivre il
est inacceptable qu'en responsables
politiques
quel que soit son pays puisse répondre
de cette façon face à une pandémie
semblable à celle que nous affronterons
un manque patent de solidarité qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas échappé à certains à
l'image de l'ancien président de la
commission européenne jacques delors le
climat qui semble régner entre les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement et le manque
de solidarité européenne font courir un
danger mortel à l'union européenne
le prochain conseil européen doit se
réunir sous quinzaine
un délai qui laisse largement le temps
aux coronavirus d'éprouver la solidité
de l'union et de ses fondations